[Music]
as you can see we are all all of them
the people are young they need in a
comfortable a peaceful life there's
nothing quite like having any field play
your mother it's somewhat surreal moment
of my life
it is not about being able to sing it's
about the support and the friendship
more people should listen to comedians
and fewer people should listen to
politicians
[Music]
all along this part of the border there
are sites like this even though it's
been clear for three days that the
border with Europe will not be opened
they still come just in case and that's
the thing many of them here are migrants
who had actually begun to settle in
Turkey but dropped everything when they
were told the border was opened thinking
Europe would be better
twenty-two-year-old Omid Mohammed is
from Afghanistan how long have you been
in Turkey it's about 2 or 3 years I have
been here
the UNSCR they have give us Kim the card
the card and they cancel it
they cancel it we cannot go to house
hospital we cannot find for ourselves a
normal boot we cannot rent a home and we
are compelled from here to go to Europe
so have you been into Greece in the past
two days no no we were in the report the
border they sent us back the Greeks
yeah the Greece folders and what did
they do to you yeah what did the Greek
soldiers do they just girls fighting you
know and they took all the cell phones
and the clothes plus the food they sent
bakers without anything they are playing
with us to Turkey government and the
Greek government they are playing with
us such as a football game they are
passing us too right left now we are
having with ourselves
the treatments child 3 months even she
she didn't she didn't complete her three
months she's where is the humanitarian
we are we are are that humans that they
are saying that we are helping the human
beings that leading help we escaped from
Afghanistan from the we don't like
terrorism we don't like the target
killing so we escaped from there to here
to go to Europe to get a better life too
education to set and leave such a human
beings but we now now we are here I
don't know what to do we are not having
the chance to go back or to forward we
are now like a gel here is like a gel
for us we don't like to stand in Greece
we want to pass we want to pass the
Greece we want to go to the country that
they need us then they need us weed we
don't like to want free money we will go
there we will get education we will work
hard we will improve there we will also
work with them together they should
accept it as a human dish that we can be
an in a safe place
that is our demands that everyone
demands as you can see you know all all
of them the people are young all of them
are young why they are trying to pass
the borders they need in a comfortable
peace life
[Music]
any film at this week sulfur and white
is based on the true story of City
trader and Mountaineer David Tate the
story reveals how his professional
success masks a series of traumatic
secrets and struggles to come to terms
with abuse he experienced during his
childhood this is part of the film sit
well David is now an NSPCC ambassador
joins us here in studio along with Hugo
Stone who you just saw in the film who
played him as a ten year old great to
see you both here David the key message
from this film that you come away with
is how many children who are abused just
don't tell anybody why did you not feel
able to tell for so many many years
combination of shame and fear to be
honest fear of my father at an early
stage that I would be accused of being a
thief this is pretty strict
disciplinarian and then in latter years
as I got older and ironically I
understood what it was it became a shame
element what do you say David part of
this quest is to try and turn the tables
on the perpetrators in the back of my
mind and also distinguish the gross
issues all of them in one go biz should
be coming out soon John what did it feel
like playing this part it's quite a sad
part at the time I I didn't have much of
an idea what the subject matter was but
over the well when we finished filming a
year later I was told what really
happened as David as a child and it made
me think that there this this movie
means so much more to children who
should open up and I feel like this
movie could really help children in need
if it just goes around to the right
people because you've got big names
associated that you got Anna frail we
saw and Dougray Scott and that Eclipse
there so these are all people that are
on money spinners for the box offices
absolutely they they also wanted to do
the part as a because of what it was as
well which is always a great advantage
there's nothing quite like having any
field play your mother it's somewhat
surreal moment of my life
among your friends is there an awareness
about what to do if if something happens
to you as a child that you feel
uncomfortable with we had a child line
ambassador I think came in and assembly
and they are they taught us what sure
what some children go through and what
child lion does to help them education
is the first part and then prevention is
hard but doable but at the same time
distinguishes ation is perhaps the
biggest I think when you can move these
chess pieces for
[Music]
buying a pet from a puppy or kitten farm
could cost owners an extra five thousand
pounds a year according to a new study
and today a government campaign has been
launched urging the public to spot red
flags before bringing their furry friend
into the family Claire called a head of
Public Affairs at Dogs Trust and Bruce
the French Bulldog are with me in the
studio hello hello hello Claire hello
Bruce
so this is a campaign about pet fishing
Claire what is pet fishing say the
government today has launched a campaign
warning people how to avoid being pet
fish so essentially buying a pet a puppy
or a kitten where everything isn't quite
as it seems so for example if you're
buying a pet Byron online adverts
helping people to identify the red flags
that they need to avoid in order to
avoid buying a puppy and it might have
been illegally imported into the country
or might have been bred in really poor
conditions
tell us about Bruce Bruce is 16 months
old and he was sadly illegally imported
into the country as a puppy and he came
from Bulgaria and was seized at the
borders for being underaged when he was
imported and that's the case a lot of
the time isn't it that people think
they're buying an animal that maybe
eight ten weeks and actually there are a
lot less they've been taken away from
their mothers very early yes so actually
to come into the country illegally from
any new country puppies should be 15
weeks old and Bruce was much younger
than that he was very underweight when
he came into the country and so there's
lots that people can do it's just so so
important to do your research before you
decide to get a puppy in the first and
those red flags they need to be aware of
a wart and so red flags would be for
example if you're looking at an online
advert
it's really simple things you can do
like copying and pasting the contact
number for the seller and seeing if it
appears in other adverts and other sites
and it's Reaser they might be
advertising multiple litters for example
you know it would be a perfect example
of a red flag and as well it's really
really important to go and see the puppy
and its mum in the home environment that
it was bred in if they don't let you see
the moment they don't let you visit more
than once we'll see the puppy with this
mum that's a real red flag um do lots of
research ask lots of questions if the
breeder seems suspicious
in any way or is putting pressure on you
the best thing to do is walk away and
report them so ultimately you're saying
people trust your instincts absolutely
when you're looking for an animal do
your research because otherwise the cost
could be quite significant so the press
release that was issued by the
government today did a survey of bets
and showed them some bets have seen pet
bills of upwards of five thousand pounds
and for people that have inadvertently
been deceived by these unscrupulous
sellers and so it can be a huge cost for
buyers but also just absolutely
heartbreaking if you're choosing a new
member of your family to find that
they've got health issues or long-term
behavioural issues and just absolutely
heartbreaking
now you will no doubt recognize my next
guest from her TV role in Emmerdale but
there's another part of a life that she
wants to talk about to Gemma Odin
battled with anorexia for 13 years the
eating disorder left her so weak that it
brought on a heart attack while she was
still a teenager and she joins me now
you have mercifully got through your
illness but you were very sick for some
years mummy yeah my anorexia developed
at the age of just 10 years old and and
my mum and dad sent me to the doctor who
turned me away because I wasn't low
enough you may have a problem also they
deemed and and unfortunately I was left
on a waiting list and the referral kept
coming and kept getting cancelled and
before I knew it I was admitted to a
children's psychiatric unit and told if
I didn't eat or drink within 24 hours
I'd be dead and that battle with
anorexia lasted for 13 years and I'm
very fortunate and well now but I
campaign heavily so that no children or
adults have to go through the hell that
my family did I know a little bit about
this because my daughter we've talked to
also and we have talked about it many
times but the thing is a most vicious
you know got better but the thing is the
figures are alarming yeah in the last
two years alone the admissions into
hospitals have increased by 37% so as we
talked about earlier that means that
people are getting to the knife critical
level so these are this is admission
into A&E yeah into hospitals units yeah
not not to eating disorder Union to any
did you find it difficult to get the
treatment you needed when you needed it
and we my mum and dad had to fight tooth
and nail constantly over and over to get
funding for me to go into eating
disorder units and it would be a case of
I'd go into an eating disorder unit I'd
get fed up the treatment wasn't there
for me psychologically and I'd get
shipped out and sometimes when I wasn't
even ready the funding one would get a
call on a Friday to say the fundings run
out you need to come and get her she's
coming home on Monday it has been a
constant constant battle well I was
talking to some people today who are
still suffering from trying to get an
appointment um one woman I spoke to this
morning said that she's
got a letter saying that it's 20 months
before she can get people and even an
appraisal assessment yeah people don't
even to get onto death's door to be able
to get help where is the logic in that
where is it that there's humanity in
that IKEA and the thing is I have been
talking openly since I got Emmerdale for
the last 10 years I've been patron of my
parents wonderful charity seed which is
support and empathy for eating disorders
and I've been talking about this for 10
years and although there are slight
improvements still not enough military
wives tells the story of a group of
women who became a media sensation and a
global movement faced with the absence
of their partners who were serving on
various tours including Afghanistan the
women formed a choir on a military base
they were followed by groups across the
world and their story has now been given
the Hollywood treatment of a look
[Music]
are you going to be okay when I'm gone
my fifth tour of course I will cause
again I'm Kate Barkley Colonel Barclays
wife let's come up with some exciting
activities to do while our service
people are away what about singing
singing let's just get the strippers in
singing Club is gonna be a lot of fun
and uplifting and there'll be a few
beers afterwards women who share that
story are sharin Wiggly Sarah Preston
and Joe our mill folk who joined me now
good afternoon ladies the ministry wife
Squire is such a global phenomenon and
so many people know your story do they
do it justice on the big screen yeah I
think they do there's quite a few bits
that it definitely catapulted me back to
a time and place I'm not in anymore and
so it's raw emotion but there's various
things they've got us through our first
performance for the choir program we
were in the pannier market in basketball
and the lady is still that in the in the
movie as well how much of a support was
it for you because your son was a raw
marine and was killed in Afghanistan how
much was that Network vital for you when
I first lost my son you know the people
who would say things like what didn't
think things like that really happened
but to go and join a choir where there
are women who know exactly where I'm
coming from and why sometimes I'll just
stand there and mouths words and not
saying it is not about being able to
sing and join me singing because thing
is really good for you it's great stress
buster
but it's about the support and the
friendship yeah and long may continue
[Music]
[Music]
it's nearly nine years since the death
of the musician Amy Winehouse so today
the name of the 27 year old is being
added to the music Walk of Fame in
Camden it's also a fundraising event
that's taking place for the Amy
Winehouse Foundation is charity which
aims to prevent the effects of drug and
alcohol misuse on young people join us
now is Amy's father Mitch and mother
Janice it does three different things
doesn't it I understand part of which is
Amos place which provides a sensuous
hope for vulnerable young women tell us
how that works it's a recovery how some
women who were in in recovery and who
after coming out of rehab still
struggling with their issues they've got
nowhere to go
and so they can stay with us amy's place
for up to two years and it's an
absolutely incredible project and we're
very proud of it this nine nine years
nine years as its Amy died and as you
look back on that time who some people
have to pinch themselves and struggle to
believe it's almost a decades since she
died what's the legacy that you hope
she's left behind the music legacy will
take care of itself but again as we said
there's so much more you know our
schools project in the last three years
the people who run our schools project
who are primarily they're all in
recovery they've addressed over 300,000
young people not only about alcohol and
drugs but other things that affect young
people today what happened was a
terrible blow not only for the family
but for all of her fans and everybody
and yet I think that she would be very
pleased about the positive outcomes that
we're getting at the moment what kind of
lessons do you think we can draw from
the way
Amy's demons ultimately saw it and her
musical talent ended so so cruelly at
such a young age what we've learned what
I know is is that as a family we we try
to protect home in the best way that we
could but we didn't know what we were
doing and so our not that would have
made any difference I mean we you know
we try to protect time in the best way
that we can but I think the important
thing is is throughout
again through our schools project is to
teach people how to be able to speak to
their parents and have
parents to speak to the air to their
children so that they're able to have
serious conversations rather than
screaming and shouting which is
basically what we had a lot of the time
[Music]
mentor former shipyard apprentice who
became a national treasure Billy
Connolly has told Sky News that he is
definitely finished with stand-up
despite having expressed an interest to
one day return to the stage he was
speaking to our arts and entertainment
correspondent Lucy Carter just tell me
about this artwork and not everyone will
know you for an artist how did it all
come about very strange it's it's almost
very nice someone see I started a few
years ago when I was on tour in Canada I
was miserable in the cold and I went to
announce shop across from their tail in
Montreal and I bought a sketchbook I'd
never drawn before and both sketchbook
and started to draw abstractly Islands
little islands in the sea it was just a
hobby and here we are and it's lovely to
wallow in it so we won't see you back on
stage we'll win more no it's my big the
Parkinson that's made my brain work
differently and you need a good brain
for a comedy you need to everything you
see should have five or six alternatives
behind it did you'd say something and
attack it from behind and let the story
make itself up and it said it's a madly
exciting thing to do this story is
taking place and you don't know where
it's going and it's a delay it's a
privilege to be part of it despite the
fact that you've been very public about
having Parkinson's you don't seem to be
slowing down I don't think it's a good
idea to slow down I have ideas and gross
opinions on it I don't think you should
let compartment ins define you I just do
my life and if my hands too shaky I
don't draw you know I'll draw later when
it stops shaking have you been surprised
how much you can achieve and how your
life can kind of continue despite that
I'm surprised and delighted but the the
ideas I had were right that you can do
anything you'll please and I hope little
schoolboys and school leavers are
watching me doing these things and see
if you can do what you like you can
write please you can write songs you can
be funny on stage you can play the banjo
you do drawings you can see and do what
you like
and people will listen and sometimes
it'll get you in trouble but that's okay
some things are meant to get you in
trouble sometimes being in trouble is a
good thing the point so to the point so
the badness and something that should be
changed more people should listen to
comedians and fewer people should listen
to politicians
[Music]